ليث جعار من مستشفى ابن سينا مراسل
الجزيره ليث اذا مع هذه الصور ربما تتضح
اكثر تفاصيل الصوره وما حدث حدثنا اكثر
اذا بعد ورود هذه الصور عن السيناريو الذي
حدث في
المستشفى نعم يعني في ساعات الفجر الاولى
كان هناك تسلل لوحدات خاصه اسرائيليه نحو
مستشفى ابن سينا في مدينه جمين حيث وصلت
هذه الوحدات الخاصه الاسرائيليه على
دفعتين الدفعه الاولى كانت ترتدي ضي
الاطباء حيث وصلت حيث وصلت هذه القوه الى
الطابق الثالث من مدخل الطوارئ نحو الطابق
الثالث في المستشفى وقامت بفتح احد الغرف
التي يتواجد بها الشبان والمقاومين
الثلاثه قام الاحتلال باطلاق النار عليه
بشكل مباشر عبر
مسدسات بكاتم للصوت ومن ثم انتحبت هذه
القوه والمكونه من ثلاثه اشخاص نحو الطريق
او نحو مثال الطوارئ فيما كانت قو ثانيه
تتكون من سبعه اشخاص قد وصلت الى وصلت
بالفعل الى وسط ال مدخل الطوارئ وقامت
بتامين دخول الوحدات الخاصه وانسحابهم
بشكل مباشر من داخل المنطقه من داخل مدخل
الطوارئ وانسحبت على الفور اثناء انسحابها
تم كشف هذه الوحده الخاصه واطلق النار
عليها بشكل مباشر من قبل المقاومين لكن
كانت الوحدات الخاصه الاسرائيليه قد هيات
نفسها للانسحاب فبالتالي قامت على الفور
بالانسحاب شهود العيان اكدوا بان هذه
القوه قد دخلت الى مدينه جنين والى مستشفى
بنسنا عبر مركبات تحمل لوحات فلسطينيه تم
وضع هذه المركبات في مناطق قريبه من
المستشفى فبالتالي سع الاحتلال بعد تنفيذ
العمليه على الفور للانسحاب من المنطقه
فيما كانت قوات الاحتلال واليات عسكريه قد
باشرت بتامين خروج هذه الوحدات الخاصه من
المخيم وكانت على استعداد لاي اقتحام في
حال يعني اي تمت او لم يخطط او لم يقم
الوحدات الخاصه الوحدات الخاصه بما كان
مخطط له على الفور وصل الفلسطينيين الى
المخيم الى المستشفى مستشفى النسه وباشروا
ب يعني اعمال البحث عما جرى داخل هذا
المستشفى ليصبح بتصفيه ثلاثه مقاومين وهم
محمد وباسل الغزاوي من كتيبه جنين التابعه
لسرايا القدس
وايضا القائد في كتائب الشعيد عز الدين
القسام محمد جلال وهو اسير محرر ومطارد
للاحتلال منذ ما يزيد عن اي سنه ونصف او
عام ونصف العام في مدينه جنين حوال
الاحتلال اعتقال ذويه للضغط عليه لتسلم
نفسه ولكن رفض وفشلت كل محاولات الاحتلال
بالوصول اليه فبالتالي سعى الاحتلال او
قام الاحتلال باغتياله وتصفيته في هذه
الليله والانسحاب مباشره من مدينه جنين
بعد ذلك وخلال الساعات الصباح اقتحم
الاحتلال وضمن السياسه والعمليه العسكريه
المتواصله لجيش الاحتلال في جنين افتح
منطقه حي المراح شرق المدينه ونفذ عمليه
عمليه اقتحام لمنازل عده بحسب بيان او
الدعاء جيش الاحتلال انها تعود لمطلوبين
حاول اعتقالهم او
تصفيتهم ضمن اي يعني محاولات الاحتلال
الحثيثه للقضاء على المقاومين والعناصر
المسلحه في شمال الضفه الغربيه المحتله
والتي باتت يعني
خلال الاشهر السابقه قد يعني دادت من
وسيرتها وثيره الاستهداف وال المتواصل ضد
الاهداف والنقاط الاسرائيليه
والمستوطنين في هذه الاثناء اعلن عن او تم
التاكيد على اعلان بيان القوى الوطنيه
والاسلاميه في مدينه جنين لاغلاق او
لاعلان حاله الحداد والاضراب العام
والشامل في كافه ارجاء المدينه حدادا على
ارواح الشهداء الذين تم اغتيالهم في
مستشفى ابسنا في مدينه جنين وان وانه
سيبدا التحضير خلال اللحظات لمراسم تشييع
جتمان الشهداء الثلاثه نحو مخيم جنين ومن
ثم نحو مبره الممرات الرف